please be with you welcome to the Dean
show subscribe if you haven't already I
often think seriously how I can
communicate the importance of talking
about serious issues like we talked
about an'desha land I tend to want to
communicate to the people this
importance and in different ways of just
thinking of us in life being on up on a
long journey via de train a plane and at
one point this journey is going to end
and that's the journey of life so while
we're here the intellectual people the
sincere people they know now that
there's got to be more to life there's
got to be a true purpose and they
believe that design indicates the
designer and he's best to tell us what
this purpose is so that's what we talked
about on the Dean show really serious
issues and what we're going to be
discussing today is between the two
monotheistic religions Islam which is
the fastest growing religion out there
and more people are coming to it each
and every day because they see the the
the evidence adds up it's logical as
rational and then we have Christianity
and many people take this mighty
messenger as a god next to God so we're
going to be in this episode looking at
the evidence that they use so we can
come to know is this something that adds
up or doesn't so we're going to be
taking the clear verses that prove that
he was indeed a messenger this is the
Islamic viewpoint the one that really
makes sense to a lot of people that's
why people come to us on and then the
doubtful versus the ambiguous verses
that people want to use to prove that he
is God Almighty or the literal Son of
God so if you're one of those that tuned
in and you really are confused about
this matter we're going to look to
unconfuse you in this episode of the
Dean show so you continue continue on
with this very important journey here on
the D show will be right back this is
this is the back here on the Dean show
Salaam alaikum peace be with you why he
gonna sell our what lucky but I got
together well see him I'll just about to
call you in Ron because i was thinking
of my dear brother who you know and I
know how is he doing pretty good he's my
teacher saw differently think he'd be
watching we can send him salaams show
salam alikum runway let him run now now
I opened up the show a lot of times we
know the serious nature of this topic
and I had made an example of life
thinking about it as if you're on a
journey you're on this train and the
Train want rise sooner or later is going
to end you're gonna have to get off the
train this life will end and some people
are just into all of the different
entertainment mental laziness whatever
it is all religions are the same i'm
just going to fight then you end up
making up your own religion atheists you
know they try to deny God but internally
they really deep down believe in God but
then they also end up making up their
own superstitions and religious and why
do you say what do you say to people to
even get them to this step to thinking
and reflecting and were the important so
they can get to you know examining the
different religions that are making the
claim to their the truth mashallah you
have asked a very important subject that
you know how do we bring people first is
even to start thinking about about
religion oh right religion or wrong
religion or no religion the first and
foremost most important thing is severe
not here in this world by our choice no
one asked us before bringing us here so
someone else has actually placed us here
so that someone else is the one who is
running the show for us and we need to
know what he wants from us if not then
it's almost like you know we have a
mobile phone if it doesn't work what do
we do we dump it we destroy it similarly
we may be destroyed as well if we do not
fulfill the purpose of our creation so
first and foremost it's a very important
thing every person to be asked is the
purpose of life why are we here and by
whom are we here whoever has placed us
here has the right to dictate our life
and regulate it and the one who created
as the man
sharra the producer would tell us the
best way to live and lead this life now
i'm sure the the people who are tuning
in now they hopefully they've gotten to
that point yeah they've gone through
many of the superficial things had the
material things it's not bringing joy
and happiness in one's life so now
they're like maybe on that quest there's
some confusion now the monotheism
monotheistic religions you would say the
top would you say the top three would be
or the top two is from its aesthetic
Christianity so now they've looked at
all the other religions pantheism it
doesn't make sense you know Hinduism all
these other thousands of God's whatnot
they came to Islam and Christianity yet
okay but now we go on in the divide no
we believe that Jesus was a mighty
messenger who was sent by God calling
the people to worship God but he never
claimed to be God so people from their
upbringing many they were taught they
just go with the flow they slide it in
on church on Sundays and praise Jesus
and God and Trinity and it's all
confusing we are here to set the record
straight to click to on including show
different so let's start off with some
of the clear verses that suck that that
are clear from the Bible show that
substantiate also the Muslim claim that
Jesus was not God sent by God but he was
indeed a servant a messenger of gosh
we'll go to that secular had first and
foremost a las manos allah says in the
quran in surah Le Mans remember three I
number 64 I auto belay initiate on the
regime pelea al al khattab lol Akali
mattandsarah in banana by Nicole M Lorna
Buddha e la la la soupe our analysis
said to the people of the book
especially referring to the Jews and the
Christians come to common terms as
between as in you and the first common
term that allah so allah speaks about is
a la nada a la la that we worship none
but the true God so this is what is the
command of allah so allah in the quran
and which is further reiterated in the
concept of god in a nutshell in the
quran which is suitable a class as they
say the touchstone of theology in the
quran which is surah number 112 are
number one which is who allah i had say
he is allah the one and only now when we
go back to the Bible and see the
statements in the Bible
made by Jesus himself or the previous
prophets or the the general context in
the Bible so let us see some of the
verses there's a verse in the Bible in
the Old Testament said by Moses peace be
upon him in book of Deuteronomy chapter
6 verse 4 lady says shamma Israel ooh
Adonai elohenu Adonai HUD hear o Israel
the Lord our God is one Lord now
amazingly the same is repeated by Jesus
peace be upon him in the New Testament
where he says in gospel of mark chapter
12 verse 29 shamma israel adonai elohenu
adonai HUD hear o Israel the Lord our
God is one Lord now these two verses are
setting this the tone straight the
concept is there is only one God and if
you go in the Old Testament all the
previous prophets including Moses peace
be upon him had never even if spoken of
a dual or a triune God doesn't that mean
that it was never part of the plan to
have a double a dwell or a triune God by
the Almighty or the concept of Trinity
ever did Moses ever understand Trinity
no it was never there rather God said in
the Old Testament in book of Deuteronomy
chapter five verse seven to nine book of
Exodus chapter number three if chapter
number 20 verses three to five he said
that I am a jealous God and there will
never be a second God book of Isaiah
chapter number 43 were some 11 book of
Isaiah chapter number 45 was over five
book of Isaiah chapter number 46 one
number or 79 he says that I am the only
God I am the only Savior there is no one
else besides me so God is making it
absolute clearly there is only one God
so let us see now what Jesus peace be
upon him has to say to his people he
says further to his people after saying
that there is only one God he says in
Gospel of Matthew chapter number 19
verses 16 and 17 to the person who comes
to him and says good master he says he
replies too many says there is none good
except one that is God he's not even
taking the small title like good for
himself he's differentiating himself
from God he goes further and he says if
you want to enter paradise if you want
to enter into life into eternal life
keep the commandments he's not saying
you have to believe in me as God never
did he say one more word Gospel of John
chapter 5 verse 30 he makes it absol
click is still clear that he's never any
part of divineness he says I can of my
own self do nothing as I here I judge
and my judgment is just because I seek
not my will but the will of the Father
who has sent me so we covered three now
hear o Israel the Lord thy God is one
our God your God this is his one so he's
being he's separating himself from from
the diviners on the vine yeah so that
makes sense so and then similar the
second Matthew 1916-17 Matthew 19
chapter 19 verses 16 and this is in
every version of the free version of the
way it hasn't changed yet yeah and then
the third one is the the one where he
says I can do nothing by myself so when
someone says I can do nothing by myself
at least he isn't God at least ease in
God because he's saying I can do nothing
by myself God is someone by any
definition of the world someone who can
do everything by himself and if Jesus is
I can do nothing by myself that really
clearly clarifies that he's claiming i'm
not god that's deep I can't do nothing
except what God Almighty gives me the
permission to do he's saying it is
clear.its there and what we have of the
Bible left we're going to go ahead and
take a break and come back we cover
three we'll get some more some clear
where these are pretty clear
straightforward yeah okay we'll be right
back with more Hannity show don't go
anywhere please subscribe to the dvo
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below please
also help support the V show by making a
donation in the link below back here on
the DS Shaw and we're talking about one
of the mightiest messengers and and
again I know that this can be a very
sensitive topic for some people but
notice we're not ridiculing Jesus we're
not mocking him drawing funny pictures
of him like many people do we think
that's a great disrespect to this mighty
messenger and you can actually go to the
Hellfire if you deny that he was a
messenger sent by the Creator according
to Islamic teachings yeah right it's an
article of faith to believe to love him
so we love him dearly but we only say of
him what he said of himself what God
said of him that he was a servant a
messenger of god and he never claimed to
be God yet that's right so we're talking
about the clear verses you mentioned
three yep and when tell us for the [ __ ]
you tell us some more yes no
Jake Locker but already the other words
is Gospel of John chapter 17 verse 3
where Jesus is not this is the remember
this is the worst which resembles with
the Islamic Creed as well you know Lyla
illallah Mohammad Rasool Allah so Jesus
says in Gospel of John chapter 17 verse
3 he says and this is life eternal that
you might know thee the only true God
and Jesus Christ whom thou has sent so
what DS asst is saying is this is the
purpose he's saying that you got to know
the only true God and Jesus thou whom
have sent which means la illaha illallah
as mohammed rasoolallah he's saying I
ISA Rasulullah he's saying there is a
you have to know the true God and you
got to know me the prophet of God has
been sent by God this again
differentiating himself from the
divinity of God he's not saying the
purpose of your life is to know me the
only true God now he's saying your
purpose of life is to know him the only
true God and Jesus Christ the one whom
have been sent by God so this is another
clear words where Jesus actually
separates himself from the divinity of
God so if you're sending someone away
you're not the same not the same person
and all there's no possible and the same
language is using the Bible in the Old
Testament for previous prophets Moses
sent by God David sent by God Jesus
similarly sent by God I think people if
they don't want to just be stuck on
cultural norms or their family's
traditions following their ancestors
their grandfathers blindly this makes
sense true it makes and most people when
you ask them do you believe if Jesus was
God are sent by God distinctive but he
was sent by God but then when they look
back oh that's not the teachings of my
pastor at church and they'll go back to
what you know they were brought up
blindly believing let's go and go ahead
we'll go further oh there's one more
interesting words Gospel of Matthew
chapter 26 verse 39 where it mentions
that he walked further that is Jesus and
he fall on his face and prayed to God
now see this falling on the face is the
character of a servant which was done by
all the previous prophets so Jesus takes
the same position he fell on his face
and he prayed to God unless he is a
servant of God he wouldn't do that
moreover in the Bible in the King James
Version and other versions artistry as
well jesus is mentioned in the book of
Acts chapter 3 verse 20 and 26 as
servant Jesus so the word servant and
son in the Greek is synonyms to each
other so every single place in the Bible
you see son go back to the book of Acts
chapter 3 verse 26 the Greek word used
there which is translated as servant is
the same Greek word so what happens is
servant and son a son is just the same
synonym in the Bible which means Jesus
is servant of God and servant of God is
never gone now isn't it that also he's
referred to as the son of man what is it
when you say son of man like what 83
times yeah exactly you know in the Bible
if you go to it initially Jesus was
referred 83 times as only Son of Man and
then he is referred as son of God so all
of this really adds up a lot that you
know if Jesus is son of man ask anyone
is Jesus son of man the whole world
including Muslims and Christians both
agree he's not son of man so you ask a
Christian why is referred as son of man
they say it is a metaphor it is the
title of respect exactly son of man is
also a title in the Bible it is not
literal it is simply metaphor and if you
go and look at the Bible in the further
versus Gospel of Luke chapter 3 verse 38
God says Adam is the son of God so if
Adam is son of God what makes Jesus so
the difference son of God would be also
a metaphor someone close to God yes the
servant to serve and I've got exactly on
closer you know that because that is the
only says that you can extract from it
because according to the Bible there are
many people who are called as son of God
David is referred as the first Morton
David is also referred as the the
begotten Son of God according to book of
service yeah so all of this gives a very
clear picture that God is not written to
anyone as his own son rather he's
referring to them as metaphor a title
son of god meaning the good servants of
God take it easy right now some people
probably can if you want to argue a
debate some you can do that all day and
night but I think the first thing people
should do is dig dug deep in their heart
and start you know if things start
making a sense and then over here you're
resisting it because maybe you just you
know stubbornly want to just hold on to
what you've been taught for your whole
life I think you cannot go wrong with
deep down inside asking the crater say
God Almighty these guys are you know you
tuned in right now that's a sign show
ask God Almighty directly guided me if
this is the truth here guiding me to
but one key thing is only asking God
Allah true exactly and this is what
exactly the teaching of all the previous
prophets did Moses ever tell his
congregation his students his disciples
to worship to someone else other than
God no he said good god ask God all the
previous prophets did the same how could
it suddenly change at the time of Jesus
rather Jesus himself is falling on his
face praying to God he's put on the
cross he called cries out to God ello
ello lama sabachthani all we are saying
is just called the same God whom Jesus
called that's it but no intermediaries
direct dial up is there any other
clearly show there's one more was that I
just wanted to perform a book facts
chapter 2 verse 22 Jesus's Hayes to his
disciples he says Jesus of Nazareth a
man approved of God in the midst of you
doing wonders and miracles and
fulfilling the signs now this again is a
clear text Jesus is saying Jesus a man
approved of God it's not the other way
around god made man no it's a man
approved of God that's a gain the sign
of a prophet of God Wow so we covered
how many was that so I think total six
to seven now six to seven so we got and
these are pretty straightforward cliff
oh man this is ax what backs 222 tax to
verse 22 he's saying this is man yes a
man a man a plan a God approved by God
yes and not God became man no I'm saying
a man approved the God we have you know
some people say look why did he have to
come like showing off that he's God and
it's like undercover guy but you know we
make this example of if the president
can you go ahead and like yeah well
we'll see exactly you know if someone's
if I say I'm the president of alpha
Prime Minister of Australia you would
say okay are you or are you not and if
you see I never claimed to be Prime
Minister whereas Tony Abbott the current
prime minister of australia claims to be
the Prime Minister obviously he is the
prime minister not me because I don't
even claim so so similarly with Jesus
Jesus is not even claiming I'm god but
God in the Bible is claiming I am God
Yahweh or a low or Allah and he's never
saying I'm God so how could you throw
the title on him when he has never
claimed but the other one is claiming
and he himself is worshipping to him and
this is our salvation I mean he'd have
to come up straight forward that's what
you always say there is not any there is
no clear unambiguous statement you'd
have to if he's guide is it look I and
the one who exactly do I'm God believe
in me my resurrection my blood otherwise
you're going to hell exactly there are
two people claiming to be Prime
Minister's one of them does not claim
and one claims then obviously the one
who is not claiming has to be given the
benefit of doubt there that is not the
the Prime Minister because he himself is
not claiming and there is not a single
unequivocally statement in the entire
Bible where Jesus said I am God or very
said worship Me that is really a very
powerful evidence to see for and we've
seen when you initially opened up you
quoted some clear verses where God
Almighty is identified I am your God
don't take any other gods besides and he
said I'm jealous God even says in the
Bible in the Old Testament book of
Isaiah chapter 45 verse 5 and book of
Deuteronomy chapter 5 verse 7 29 he says
I'm a jealous God meaning if you have
another one taken as God or you worship
Him that's it that's the end of your
relationship with God before we go to
break I think you also you mentioned
this one where it was it in the tron
Amir Exodus where God Almighty saying
thou shalt have no other gods except the
one guy this is like the Kali ma Shakti
right of Exodus chapter 20 verse 35 very
straight like there's no image of God
never make any image of God God is only
one there's no one besides them it's so
powerful and so close to the ties with
Islam except that you actually realize
here now that this is llamas only the
continuation of the true teachings of
Christ and it says you should worship no
one in the heavens so no angels or they
ain't people with no angels nothing on
the earth and beyond the earth and now
Jesus was even in the world even in the
water and don't make any graven image of
any likeness of anything heavens above
on the earth or beneath the earth that's
it that's that's clear I think we did we
did justice to the clear verses from the
Bible now we're going to come back with
some of the ambiguous verses that people
use that can be interpreted that way
this way we'll put them in their proper
context here on the DS show don't go
anywhere please subscribe to the dvo
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below please
also help support the V show by making a
donation in the link below
back here on the Dean show now what do
we say you you gotta be earnestly inside
your heart yourself asking your maker
the one who made you guide me guide me
if these guys are on to something guide
me to what's the truth that's it clear
make it simple and you can again come
from a Christian background we're not
trying to disparage on anybody not
trying to intentionally upset or hurt
anybody we're just trying to make this
true very apparent and which it is and
clear we talked about the clear verses
now let's get into some of the the other
verses that people will use to justify
that he was gone yeah let's start with
one I throw at you I think a very
popular one is John 157 yep yep first
John 57 yeah yes can you go ahead see
first of all a lot of analysis in the
Quran in surah nisa Scott number 4 I
number 171 well at the hulu thalassa do
not say trinity so God is actually
clearly kind of commanding keep away
from this concept of Trinity which is
not the right one so let us see now what
the Bible says about this and this is
actually used as a proof by those
Christians who claim to be following
Jesus and Jesus and they believe that
Jesus is God so this is mentioned in the
Bible in the King James Version in First
Epistle of John chapter 5 verse 7 that
just you mentioned it reads in the
heaven there are three that bear witness
the Father the Son and the Holy Ghost
and these three are not three but one so
now this is the words that a Christian
is generally taught in the church and he
picks up this one as the proof that God
is is three in one now point number one
this worse of three in one was never
found in the Old Testament so Moses and
all the previous prophets for thousands
of years were not aware at all of the
concept of Trinity that there is a three
in one God at ever they never mentioned
a triune God second point this verse has
now been in the new versions the Revised
Standard Version the New Revised
Standard Version the American Standard
Version and the NIV has been removed
completely and it has been mentioned in
the preface that this is this these
verses that were removed what corruption
concoction and Eddie
in the Bible the ones who removed it
were 32 great scholars of highest
eminence in the Christian world back by
52 denominations so it was not a Muslim
work it was not an anti-christian work
it was the work of the top Christian
scholars now what happens here is why
did they remove the words they said
because we could not find it in the
original text the original manuscript
the original Scripture so when it is
removed there is no words which is
actually talking about three in one God
there is not a single words now which
says three in one so if the worse is
removed which was the basis by the
Christian scholars and it gives a proof
that there is no other evidence to even
think right now that there is a three in
one guard so when the reverse is removed
by the Christian scholars eye on you as
lame people as lay people have got no
option other than to agree that this is
not part of Bible and this is not the
belief of Christianity now this is by
what is it like 3282 eminent scholars
scholars of christian backed by 52
denominations so there's no one's
objecting to it everyone's agreed this
was does not belong to the Bible it was
thrown out it was thrown out okay so
let's go they have only come closer to
what a loss it in the Quran in surah
nisa surah number for a number 171 well
at the pool fellas I do not say Trinity
so there is no more words as in about of
Trinity there at all now just before you
go on for the people who've heard the
name Allah the first time jesus and
Aramaic he would call him God biol aha
yes Vidya so we're talking Arabic
language yes and Jehovah would simply
Jehovah would give me the everliving God
this is the same creator we're talking
about yes so jaha is a jay jay added is
a Jay added as in America I heard the
moment I walked in America they said
don't do jaywalking here and you can
find so JS has a jaywalking in the Bible
at times for some reason let's keep it
away the actual name is Yahweh Yahweh
Yahweh if you go to the Arabic name of
Allah is yeah hi you yeah uh yeah hi you
yeah way so you have the Arabic yeah
that yeah in hebrew is voir yeah yeah
yeah hi you Yahweh it's the same word
and we both of them means they ever
living so arabic and have your sister
languages nouns we are very similar in
the you know pronunciation hallelujah ya
allah who exactly so if you just
destroyed
back how could there be so many similar
it can be made up all the signs
according to exactly every name of God
is just matching with every name of God
in Islam it cannot be a conscious the
same God the ones god let's go to
another this other worse now this is a
very powerful verse every Christian
general you ask him is Jesus God they
say yes and you ask him to prove John 11
John Gospel of John chapter 1 verse 1
the word sleeves in the beginning was
the word the Word was with God and the
Word was God so now here let me read it
again to just make it clear break it
down into three parts in the beginning
was the word the second is the Word was
with God and the third is the Word was
God so what the Christian claims here is
the word in the Bible here refers to
Jesus and God is obviously the father
according to the Bible so if you now
change it the word with Jesus we will
see what it sounds like this is what the
Christian claims in the beginning was
Jesus Jesus was with God and Jesus was
God so sexy leaders God according to the
Bible now how do we respond to this
first and foremost this statement John
11 is not spoken by John is not even
spoken by Jesus John did not say this is
what Jesus said rather the history
historical facts proved that this verse
was actually a statement made by the
Phillips of Alexandria long before even
Jesus came on earth so it was the
predominant worse amongst the Greeks
those who believe in polytheism so they
said this statement it is not a
statement of Jesus point number two
let's allow the difference you know let
orc it say for the sake of argument ed
was this statement of the Gospel of John
made by John so he said in the beginning
was the word no word in the Bible has
two meanings word is Jesus and word also
means the Word of God is the Bible they
call it the Word of God so it's not
Jesus but it's word of god it's a word
about him word of God similarly if you
translate that as a word of god there's
no problem now this is that word was
Jesus okay even if that was Jesus God
that is coming twice in this verse in
the beginning was the word the Word was
with God and the Word was God the second
God is a different God to the first
God in that worse the first g.o.d is
Haute yours in the Greek the second
g-o-d God is tante yours John Theus
means someone from God who chose means
true God and the same God which is a
small g-o-d is used in the Bible by
Jesus to other people as well in book of
Exodus chapter 7 verse 1 where Jesus
said you all are gods and that God has
to be the small g-o-d similarly here it
is a small g.o.d a small g.o.d would
mean someone from God or a prophet of
God so not let's read it again turn the
small g-o-d into prophet of God in the
beginning was the word the Word was with
God the Word was prophet of God makes
sense it makes more sense yes we covered
too we're almost at a time a last one we
only got time for one more one more okay
so what we did the other one that we can
cover is they used Gospel of John
chapter 3 verse 16 for God so loved the
world that He gave His only begotten Son
so this is he Jesus is begotten Son now
this is yes it is Darren King James
Version i agree but in the Revised
Standard Version a new international
version the word the word the title
begotten is removed from Jesus so if
begotten is removed Jesus is son of God
everyone is son of God according to the
Bible another book of psalms chapter 2
verse 7 it says that David is begotten
Son of God so if David is begotten and
Jesus's begotten then what's the big
difference rather Jesus being the garden
has been removed from the Bible further
so it leaves everyone as a son of God
according to the Bible anyone who does
the work of God is son of god Adam his
son of God David is son of God Solomon
is son of God the previous prophets are
sons of God Bible even says sons and
daughters of God in book of Genesis so
just shows that Bible has a language son
of God I come to America all the oldies
the old ankles call me was him my son
does not mean I'm his little son it only
means a metaphor or respect so God is
saying son of God which refers to a
servant of God in the Bible thank you
very much you're at a time we had a lot
more that we can cover but we gotta go
we gave people a nice little taste test
of clear verses ambiguous it's really
clear that Jesus was sent by God calling
the people to worship the crater and not
the creation exactly yes
that's that's the message that's the
message all as I think I what you did
I'll just repeat that pray to that one
God seek help from that one God as you
me guide you to the right path beautiful
thank you so much you're like oh
something and I think that was pretty
clear we had the clear verses that are
straightforward you don't need to be a
rocket scientist you don't need us Bible
scholar it's straightforward here you
see their kind of ambiguous but when
they put in their context again it's
straightforward and we would agree that
Jesus indeed he was the way the truth
and the light that's right at his time
he was a messenger sent by God in the
depths of darkness people weren't so he
was guiding people to delight what's the
like the knowledge of God the guidance
from god this will set you on a path to
get to God to get to his paradise to his
pleasure Moses at his time he was the
way the truth and the light Muhammad is
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind a profit that Jesus talked about
he was coming and he never also called
people to worship Him nor did Jesus know
that Moses no to Abraham Abraham he
wasn't a Jew or Christian but he was one
who submitted himself entirely to the
will of God and this is what Jesus
called you to do also and Muhammad being
the last and final messenger these were
the best of creation they were
messengers of God teaching us how to get
the pleasure of God how to get to
paradise how to avoid a Hellfire and it
starts with you earnestly understanding
that this life will end like that plane
ride that train ride and at the end
don't wait until death comes to figure
it out now is the time and by asking the
Creator to guide you definitely he'll
facilitate a way if you're sincere
subscribe if you haven't already and
continue to tune in to the Dean show
we'll see you next time until that peace
be with you please subscribe to the
Biggio follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below please also help support the V
show by making a donation in the link
below